lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
enseñarte otra forma de sumar números
bueno es una forma que yo utilizo
siempre que voy a sumar números en mi
cabeza
así es que digamos que por ejemplo
quiere sumar 5 más 68 y bueno ya hemos
visto algunas formas de hacer esta suma
de hecho hay muchísimas formas de hacer
esto pero la forma que vamos a ver
ahorita puede ser muy útil sobre todo si
estás haciendo esta suma en tu cabeza y
yo cuando veo números como 68 a veces se
me ocurre pensar en que bueno a este
número 68 si le suman a yo 12
llegaríamos a 70 y entonces por qué no
tomamos este 5 y lo partimos en un 2 y
un 3 sumamos el 2 a 68 para llegar a 70
y ya después sumamos el 3
así es que qué es lo que nos va a quedar
bueno pues tomamos el 5 y lo vamos a
separar en 3
2 o qué
5 es 32 y la razón por la que estoy
partiendo el 5 en 32 es para tener aquí
este 2 para sumarlo al 68 y llegar hasta
70 entonces nos falta por aquí sumar 68
y otra vez la razón por la que queremos
tener aquí este 2 es porque nos
preguntamos cuánto le tenemos que sumar
a 68 para llegar a 70 y eso pues es 2
entonces podemos reescribir esto como
tres más dos más 68
pero ahora sumarle el 2 al 68
y entonces 268 esta suma de aquí 268 es
70 pero pues también le tenemos que
sumar este 3 de aquí y entonces tenemos
3 más 70 que es igual a 73 puede parecer
como un procedimiento demasiado largo y
si lo escribes y está bastante largo
pero esto está hecho más bien para que
lo piensas en tu cabeza
ok está sumando 568 y puedes pensar oye
cuánto le tengo que sumar a 68 para
llegar a 70 y pues le tienes que sumar 2
entonces pues vamos a dividir al 5 en 3
más 2 el 2 se lo sumamos al 68 para
obtener 70 y así ya nada más nos falta
sumar 3 y entonces tenemos 73 otra forma
de hacer esta suma es utilizar la recta
numérica
entonces digamos que tenemos una recta
numérica por aquí
con unas cuantas marcas déjame pongo
estas marcas
y digamos que este número de aquí es 68
entonces este número de aquí va a ser 70
y bueno lo que queremos hacer es sumar 5
y vamos a utilizar esta recta numérica
para sumarle 5 a 68 ahora podríamos en
lugar de sumar directamente 5 podríamos
empezar primero sumando 2
así es que empezamos en 68 y digamos que
sumó 2
todos y eso es justo lo que hice por
aquí teníamos 68 y le sumamos 2 para
llegar a 70 y después como quiero sumar
5 entonces tengo que sumar otros 3 más
entonces tengo 73 que pues es 73